thilo sarrazin jetzt auch zurück ja und
der rechnet mit der energiepolitik der
regierung ab und zwar wir werden
knallhart ja das ist der mann der vor
zwölf jahren hier mit diesem buch das
land aufgewühlt und aufgemischt hat
deutschland schafft sich ab seine kritik
damals an der zuwanderungspolitik an der
ganzen islam politik und jetzt knöpft
sich sarrazin die große gaskrise vor
eine politik die wie er sagt 1 verloren
hat nämlich den gesunden
menschenverstand und das ist ja auch der
nächste kosten schock für millionen
deutsche das gas dass er zwei mal gucken
wir sind eine große abrechnung von
sarrazin
er ist deutschlands umstrittenster autor
jahrzehntelang politiker ist die spd ihn
raus war thilo sarrazin nun rechnet er
knallhart ab mit der regierung lägen der
gaskrise und hier hat wohl die deutsche
politik insgesamt versagt nämlich alle
die die
unkritisch eben gesagt haben na ja wenn
das gas aus russland kommt ist doch ok
und die leitung ist noch da und die
würden ständig auf unser geld verzichten
die haben sich alle geirrt wir haben 80
millionen deutsche ich würde mal sagen
zehn millionen
millionen zehn millionen menschen in
existenznot die dramatische warnung von
sarrazin sein vorwurf die politik hat
den verstand verloren falsche
energiepolitik der ideologie wegen der
kernkraft muss weg unabhängig von den
kosten das ist ja das ausgangs dass
ausgabe der grün und jetzt in dieser
lage ist es ihnen auch wichtiger was die
als kernkraft abschaffung angeht recht
für behalten als die probleme führt für
die menschen und am energiemarkt zu
lösen was am ende der wirtschaft schadet
was dem menschen schaden und was als
muss natürlich weltweit der hat der
lächerlichkeit da hat regieren ohne
gesunden menschenverstand
sarrazin wirft scholz und habe ich vor
in der aktuellen gaskrise nicht alles zu
tun um den wohlstand der deutschen zu
sichern irgendwann 40 der bürger
veräppelt sagt wenn die viel für einen
so viel geld für dinge haben die gibt es
eigentlich gar nicht nötig sind können
eigentlich auch mal was für mich haben
und das und das sorgt dann für einen
unmut die man dann auch wieder rational
beherrschen musste und dann wird das
vierte fünfte sechste instrument kommen
und das ist natürlich ein absoluter
irrweg das ergebnis dieses politik
versagens millionen deutsche in
existenznot schafft sich deutschland in
der gaskrise ab sarrazin selbst sorgt
für den blackout vor wie er bei bild
verrät wir haben auch von also camping
gaskocher noch aus alten cap bereiten im
keller mit diesen mit diesen alten
blauen mit diesem blauen patronen den
haben wir ganz
normal überprüft er ob man noch
funktioniert und er tut ist sarrazin ein
streitbarer politiker der für den
notfall dem campingkocher bereithält
weil es der regierung an einem fehlt wie
er sagt an gesundem menschenverstand
während sarrazin mit der regierung und
ihrer energiepolitik ordentlich
abrechnet kommt schon der nächste kosten
schock für uns alle auf die gasanlage
kommt nämlich noch was oben drauf so
genannte bilanzierungs umlage und eine
gasspeicher umlage ja und dann kommt man
inklusive mehrwertsteuer pro
kilowattstunde gas mittlerweile auf
3,26 cent die das jetzt teurer wird das
ist heftig noch einmal umgerechnet für
eine vierköpfige familie im
einfamilienhaus weit über 600 650 euro
die alleine durch die vielen umlagen
jetzt das gas teurer wird
[Musik]
ganz viele menschen sagen natürlich wir
können nicht mehr und jetzt können wir
erst recht nicht mehr und ganz oft
fühlen sich auch die rentnerinnen und
rentner völlig vergessen wie frank jacke
witz unsere bild reporterin marie sophie
horstmann hat ihm gesucht
ich bin heute bei frank jacob wird in
hargesheim und auch er merkt den teuer
schock und das vor allem beim heizen
fragen ja gewiss aus hargesheim im monat
hat der rentner rund 1300 euro zur
verfügung und davon bezahlt er seine
miete sein auto versicherung und
lebensmittel vor allem seine gas heizung
springt jetzt die monatlichen kosten
ist bitter zu sehen wenn das ersparte
aufgefressen wird von der teuerung von
energiekosten die eigentlich nebensache
sein sollten und als ich das gesehen
habe dachte hier läuft irgendwas schief
und diesen staat der gaspreis anstieg
wurde vom versorger bereits an die
mieter gemeldet man ist erst mal
sprachlos
nach den neuesten zahlen wird der betrag
sich auf etwa 200 euro in zukunft
belaufen pro monat heißt 160 euro mehr
kosten eine summe die er bei seiner
rente deutlich spürt und dazu kommt noch
die neu beschlossene gasanlage ja das
sind ja auch noch mal circa 170 180 euro
die noch zusätzlich drauf kommen dazu
kommt noch das rennen hier die
sogenannte energie pauschale die im
september ausgezahlt wird nicht bekommen
also genau hier werden rentner einfach
vergessen es macht mich sehr wütend muss
ich sagen das kann ich hier vor der
kamera gar nicht so ausdrücken man hat
ja gewisse vorstellungen wie man seinen
ruhestand verbringen wird und am
wenigsten denkt man daran dass man sich
gedanken machen muss wie man seine
wohnung heißt und wie man seinen strom
bezahlen kann dass ich etwas was für
mich total unverständlich ist wie ein
land wie deutschland auf diesem standard
ist fertig bringt große teile seiner
bevölkerung jetzt vor ein armutsproblem
zu stürzen dann verkündete bundeskanzler
olaf scholz endlich eine entlastung wird
steuer auf gasverbrauch zeitlich
befristet auf 7 prozent abzusenken ein
witz denn dass frank jacob witz denn in
seinem fall bedeutet das bei der
gasanlage
145 euro mit 19 prozent mehrwertsteuer
sind das
173 euro mit dem gesenkten 7
mehrwertsteuer
155 also gerade mal eine ersparnis von
18 euro wenn man hätte wollten entlasten
dann hätte sollen diese gasanlage er das
sollte der staat tragen auch wenn er
sich dafür verschulden muss dann muss
ich nicht dem verbraucher noch diese
zusätzlichen kosten aufbürden frank
jacke witz ist enttäuscht von den
politikern gemeinsam gehen wir in den
keller und schauen uns die gasheizung
einmal genauer an
das war jeder zahlte hier dazu kommt
richtig reinhauen ich hab wird was den
stromverbrauch angeht schon einige
maßnahmen getroffen um dort den
verbrauch zu senken bei mir
hauptsächlich mein pc der relativ
leistungsstark ist und den abgesetzt für
den normalen täglichen gebrauch dann
habe ich mir ein brot backt geholt nutze
fehlt die mikrowelle stadt im backofen
ja würde ich fast schon mal sagen durch
das licht ausmachen der katze anzünden
aber dass sowohl
bei frank jacobs wird es sie bei den
meisten deutschen ein richtig teurer
winter er sagt die rentner werden von
der politik einfach vergessen
und wenn sie auch sagen mir geht es ganz
genauso ich kann auch nicht mehr alles
viel zu teuer wir hören ihnen zu wir
wollen ihnen eine stimme geben hierbei
bild live melden sie sich einfach bei
uns und vor allem bei unserem sparfuchs
schreiben sie an spar folks at
bild.de hier unten sehen sie noch einmal
die adresse also frank liest wirklich
alles was da ein geht in seinem postfach
wir wollen ihnen hierbei bild live eine
stimme geben
[Musik]